hey olivia hey kiara hi hey
all right listen the only negative thing
i'm gonna say about this show is that i
only got two
episodes i'm insanely hooked this is
such a good
show why do you think this show is so
addictive olivia let's start with you
i mean a lot of reasons i'm addicted to
it too i was so excited with every
script that we got
and i mean i'm speaking for both kiara
and i when i say that every script that
we got we would immediately call each
other and be like
whoa like it is it's
there's just oh it's just so unique i
think one the way that it's
the story is being told between two
different perspectives
and two the overall mystery yes but also
the mystery within each character in
this show i think
there are so many layers to every single
character and it's so important that
you watch and i love that that is such
an important part of this show as
we have to watch it in order to really
understand it and i think we need a show
like that something that is
going to bring us in and transport us
back to a really cool era in the 90s
and um yeah it's going to be great i'm
excited for everybody to see it
yeah me too okay so here's the thing
you're playing each a character but they
have
essentially three different
personalities depending on what year
we're focusing on so
what was that like for you you know
working with this very complex character
yeah i mean it was it was super amazing
i think that
we i connected you know really heavily
with the other actors and
you know with the creative team and they
kept me really grounded in the story and
where we were and what was going on
it you know she's complicated but she's
human
and i think that you know as human
beings we all have a lot going on in our
head and
you know there's a lot of different
feelings emotions energy and so much can
drastically change for a person over the
course of a year
so i think it was really interesting to
explore that concept you know
the idea that you can look in the mirror
and potentially not even recognize
yourself at a certain point
and i think that especially you know for
teenagers everywhere and for young
adults and
you know people coming into this age
it's it's crazy how much can happen in a
year and
you know how uh how drastically uh life
can adjust and
how much can really be going on yeah
absolutely
um so jessica biel really made a name
for herself as an executive producer on
this center another super addictive show
she's an executive producer on this show
did you guys get to talk to her did she
give you any advice
oh yeah i mean jessica was so involved
in this show and i think
it's important for everybody to know
like just how much she was involved even
if she wasn't necessarily present on set
for the entire duration of
filming season one her presence was just
so known and she
was just so collaborative and having a
producer like that
changes everything and because of how
tricky this show is to film and because
of all of the different years i think
it was so important for us to have that
communication with her
and she's incredible i mean not just as
a producer but as a human being
oh i love hearing that um so not to put
you guys on the spot but do you have a
favorite
jessica bill project i mean i grew up in
the 90s so 7th heaven
is it for me what about you guys um i
mean i honestly
i i'm totally biased because we talk
about it a lot on set with michelle and
jessica but i
i do love the center and i love jessica
in the center and i love them producing
the sinner and i i
i absolutely was addicted and obsessed
with that show and i see like a slight
reflection of
you know the concept that we're trying
to create here in that and i really
enjoyed it
what about you no i completely agree i
obsess with the center and it's one of
my this genre is one of my favorite
genres so
even before i was working on this show i
watched the center and i was
so obsessed with it and just her
performance and
her performance and everything is just
so good she's just so
good it's stupid i love it okay see i
love hearing this so much because i love
her too but you know she's actually a
really cool person is awesome
um okay so i grew up in the 90s i
remember those butterfly clips uh what
was it like for you guys going back to
the 90s and what did you learn about
that era
i mean i think i learned a lot there was
a lot i didn't know about
you know the style the hair and makeup
the technology
you know the music the movies i think
just completely being able to exit this
world we're in right now and enter
kind of an altered universe i mean we
were working in a mall and
you know all of the stores were 90s all
the clothing had been replaced all of
the signs had been changed
it was basically like being transported
to a different time which i think was an
all-around like amazing experience
what do you love about the uh the 90s
olivia uh
all of it i mean it's just such a cool
time in life i'm so bummed that i was
born and at the very end of it because i
didn't actually get to experience any of
it
um i mean the fashion is ultimately my
favorite
just because it's sort of my style
nowadays i'm
back it's back it's back and i will only
forever wear highways to jeans if they
ever go out of style i'm suing whoever
made that decision because
they're your favorite um but the
from the style to the music to just how
laid-back things were
yeah it just overall is such a cool time
yeah and just to wrap things up is it so
you guys don't know
like when you first signed on you didn't
know who the victim was
who the villain was you had to go
through the scripts and figure it all
out
that's so crazy oh my gosh so then when
you figured out what it was
mine's blonde mine's oh yeah oh yeah
brain's on the floor
love it awesome thanks so much guys
congrats on the show
to watch the rest